- How would we rate ourselves?
- I'm gonna give myself a solid six.
- [Announcer] If you had to
rank yourself against others
based on a specific trait,
what would it say about how you see them
and how they see you?
We brought together six people,
blindfolded them
and had them rank each other
based on how attractive
they thought they were.
Then they took the blindfolds off
to rearrange each other.
This is Ranking.
- I am like 5'10", 5'11".
I'm blonde.
I'm white.
I have freckles.
- I'm 5'6".
I have, like, shoulder length hair,
like, like dark brown, black.
- I am brown.
I have curly hair.
It's black.
It's short.
It's kind of in a Mohawk.
I have a lot of tattoos.
I have a sleeve.
I have a neck tattoo.
I have tattoos on my face.
I have tattoos on the side
of my head of two scorpions.
I have brown eyes, 5'6"
- I'm like 5'10", something like that.
Brown hair, it's, it's
pretty short right now
but when it grows out a bit,
it gets all curly and and nuts.
Got a little bit of facial hair.
Got a nice little stash going.
I got just about everything.
Everybody else got, got
some ears, eyes, nose.
I, I, I don't really know.
- I am brown skin.
I have black hair, 5'3" and a half.
The half is important.
Um. I'm like 115 pounds.
- I'm 5'7".
I have naturally blonde
hair, but I dye my hair,
like kind of platinum like silver, gray.
My question for everyone
is do you feel attractive?
Are you confident in yourself?
- I feel like my, the
way that I express myself
isn't conventional.
So it took a lot of hard work,
so I'm pretty proud of what I have going.
- Me as well.
I think I'm, I think I'm pretty cute. So.
- I've gotten a lot confident
definitely in the last, like, three years.
And I feel like because of that
I just feel more attractive.
- I guess I feel pretty cute.
You know, it took me a while
to get to this place,
but, hey, I feel good now.
- I would like to know what everyone
would want to change about themselves?
- I mentioned earlier that
I wanted to get top surgery.
That would just be because
I get gender dysphoria
and identifying as nonbinary
it would just help me feel
more in alignment with myself.
- I guess for me,
my goal this year is to just
kind of like, I guess, put on more muscle.
- I think for me it'd be my nose.
Just, 'cause it's pretty flat.
And every time I wanna
have, like, new glasses on
it's always a struggle
because I have to like push it up.
- I would also probably say get a nose job
but my twin would be so upset if I did.
So I won't.
- Oh, you have a twin?
- Yeah, we're identical.
She would be devastated if I did,
but I've thought about it many times.
- For me.
I kind of want to put on a couple pounds.
- My hair when it grows
out, I just can't manage it.
I can't do anything about it.
And tried so many products,
all kinds of haircuts
doesn't really do anything.
So I always gotta cut it super
short every now and then.
- How we rate ourselves.
- I mean, I guess beauty is in the eye
of the beholder, so I don't, I don't know.
I can't really say.
- I'll be safe.
I'll say eight.
- I give myself a solid nine,
just because there are
more improvements to come.
- I'm gonna give myself a solid six.
I'll take a six.
That's good.
- I sure it'll be higher than that.
(audience aw www)
- Yeah. I hope so.
(upbeat music)
- You all wanna just like say a number
that you think you'd wanna place yourself.
I know it's a really hard question.
- Well, you sound very confident.
So I would place you higher.
The most attractive
quality a person can hold
for me is confidence.
- Mm.
- Yeah.
I agree with that.
So, Zyi, do you wanna
move like this way maybe?
- Then?
- Where are you? Are you right?
- I'm all the way on the end.
- I agree with that. Yeah.
- Yeah.
- Whoever's on like, my right.
I feel like that person
seems to be the most attractive to me.
Just because that person seems, like,
really confident and, like, positive
and I'm really, like, I like being friends
with people like that. So.
- This one, over here?
- Yes.
- Oh, I mean, you can't.
- My right.
Wait, I can't see.
- You can't see.
- I don't know.
- I was pointing at
the person to my right.
- Oh. Yeah, your right.
- Okay.
- The twin. Yes.
- Oh my God. Thank you. Okay.
Is someone gonna move me
or do I walk myself?
- Where would you like to move to guys?
- Two.
- I agree with that.
Does everyone else agree?
(upbeat music)
- Is anyone, think that they shouldn't be
where they are at the moment?
- I feel pretty solid where I'm standing.
- Kyra, do you feel like, you comfortable
in, in your spot?
- Yeah. You should be higher also.
- Yeah. You said that earlier.
You didn't wanna sign
a number to yourself.
I feel like because you're so confident.
So you should move up a little.
- Okay. Um, where would you guys put me?
- Three or four.
I kind of think Zyi should be one.
If you wanna switch with Kelly.
- Okay. All right.
- Okay. So now it's Zyi
one, Ali two, Kelly three.
- Lauren four.
- Conrad five.
- Kyra six.
- We were talking about Kyra.
I don't know why.
- Yeah. So where, like three or four?
- Three? I feel like?
- Oh, sorry.
- How does everyone feel now?
- Yeah, I feel pretty happy about this.
- All right.
- It's so bright in here.
- Oh, it's bright.
- I took my mask off
and my makeup was running down my face
from the mask.
And that was horrible
because now everyone's gonna see it.
- Hi, Nice to meet you.
- You too.
- Nice to see you all.
- I was surprised about
how everyone looked
not a single person matched
what I thought in my head.
- Kelly, you sounded like you were
way taller for some reason. Like.
- You sounded taller.
- Yeah, I, I.
- I thought your voice was like
bearing down on me.
- Yeah, I thought your
voice was like way up here.
I was like, Jesus Christ.
- Honestly, Conrad.
That's how I pictured you.
- That makes sense.
- Does anyone feel like
they should be higher?
We could start with that.
Should anyone be lower?
- I feel like everyone
doesn't wanna hurt each other's feelings.
- I feel like we're all a team now.
- But we're here for this.
We signed up for it.
I won't be offended.
- I guess like I'm attracted to men.
So I guess if my line was
going this way, it'd be right.
- Do you wanna move Conrad up?
Voice your opinion.
- I mean, yeah. I'd move Conrad up.
- Just move.
- He's a good looking guy.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- Do you wanna switch?
- Yeah, sure.
Okay. I, I'll, I'll move up.
I'll move up for now.
But we're all this, this
the discussion is still on the table.
- Yeah. I dunno.
It's just a really
uncomfortable feeling to say.
I think I should be higher in this line
than you because I think I'm
more attractive than you.
- Move Kyra up.
- Would you wanna move up?
- Yeah. I mean I can move up.
- Do you wanna switch? Okay. Cool.
- Back to like the original.
I do feel like Conrad
and Lauren should switch
But I know we've switched you back.
So, that was just my opinion.
I'm not saying we should switch you back.
- Whatever works for anybody here.
- I don't mind that.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. No.
- Why not switch on back.
- For the game!
- [Announcer] Do you guys feel good
about where everyone is?
- Yeah.
- Anyone have any qualms?
- No.
- No. Okay.
- Look, y'all, I, being nonbinary.
I am beyond my body.
So to be perceived as a woman
in like those conventional
forms of like femininity
and stuff like that is
like, already a thing.
So, like, to assess
who's the most attractive
or what, it's so uncomfortable
because I, I don't know.
Everybody has unique
elements to themselves.
People can be beautiful,
gorgeous on the outside
and be so ugly on the inside.
So I'm like, nah, I need
the whole picture, y'all.
- I think that's why she's number one.
I mean, they're number one.
Sorry. I'm sorry.
- No, it's good. It's good.
- [Announcer] Anyone else
felt uncomfortable or.
- I think we all felt
pretty uncomfortable.
It's not every day you get blindfolded
and put into a room with
other people in blindfolds.
- I know, I was like, are
we actually filming a video?
Are we like being Punk'd?
That was the most
uncomfortable part for me.
- I also feel like we
all like kind of conjured
our own images of each other in our head.
So then having to like
completely rethink that
when we like took off our blindfolds,
it was a little disorienting
for me, I guess.
Beauty is from within.
And definitely confidence
is the best accessory
that you can have to any
outfit that you're wearing
or feeling good in who you are.
And attractiveness comes
as a result of that.
- Just how many versions
of myself I've had,
I've had to shed to like
get to this version.
I'm pretty proud of it.
And it was super reaffirming
that they even put me there.
- [Announcer] And Ali could we get you
back in the line with everyone?
- I, I'm so confused. I
feel like I'm not moving.
Okay. Thanks.
This is good.
'Cause I have a question
that I'll ask next, so.
How did I. What? Oh my God, guys.